This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.|||这是一个I-Heart播客。真人保证。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，如何培养心理韧性、保持体能以及建立抗压能力。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.|||经历一些艰难困苦，你终将蜕变成一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。就在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客，或任何你收听播客的地方。在《回看过去》（Look Back at it）播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和说是个重要时刻。84年对我来说也意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.|||我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当年发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论20世纪80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.|||请在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的平台上收听《回看过去》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜爱的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的《吃一堑长一智》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在其他任何地方都不太安全进行的坦诚对话，而你正在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人身披盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但仅仅因为你有这个能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。请在AHA广播应用、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的平台上收听并了解《吃一堑长一智》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.|||2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。埃伦女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试结果，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。成群的互联网侦探花了一番功夫才揭露出一个令人不安的规律。还有两名男子也经历过同样的事情。格雷格，一个女同性恋者。迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the 20s. the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the 20s. the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what|||我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《情陷囹圄》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在Iheart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的平台上收听《情陷囹圄》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《二十岁心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个探讨二十岁年龄段的播客。在这个播客中，我们探讨我们二十岁时面临的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及这些变化
they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode as we break down the psychology of our 20s. This topic today is devoted to all of my over-a-chie all of my former golden children, gifted children, perfectionists, the people who have grown up with the idea instilled in them that they needed to be the best, they needed to be doing the most to have value, to be worth something. Today we are going to break down the paradox, the curse of being an overachiever, particularly in our 20s and all of the pressure, the burnout, the anxiety,
they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode as we break down the psychology of our 20s. This topic today is devoted to all of my over-a-chie all of my former golden children, gifted children, perfectionists, the people who have grown up with the idea instilled in them that they needed to be the best, they needed to be doing the most to have value, to be worth something. Today we are going to break down the paradox, the curse of being an overachiever, particularly in our 20s and all of the pressure, the burnout, the anxiety,|||对我们的心理意味着什么。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身处世界的哪个角落，很高兴你能回来收听新的一期节目，和我们一起剖析二十岁的心理学。今天的话题献给所有追求卓越的、所有曾经的“金童”、天才儿童、完美主义者，献给那些从小就被灌输这种观念的人：他们必须做到最好，必须做最多事情才拥有价值，才有意义。今天我们要剖析的是过度追求卓越所带来的悖论和诅咒，特别是在我们二十多岁的时候，以及随之而来的所有压力、职业倦怠和焦虑，
that comes with it, kind of with the hope that we can release ourselves from the expectations we have internalized that are holding us back from actually being happy, from pursuing the kind of life that we want in a balanced and healthy fashion. We of course are also going to explore all of the psychology, the family dynamics, the early childhood experiences that have made us into the person that we are today. And navigating, I think, that identity crisis that I think we all naturally experience as we age and we mature and we realize that perhaps this version of us, this overachieving version of us, is not really who we want to be. We cannot live up to the golden child expectation. I think growing up, many of us who are labeled as quote unquote,
that comes with it, kind of with the hope that we can release ourselves from the expectations we have internalized that are holding us back from actually being happy, from pursuing the kind of life that we want in a balanced and healthy fashion. We of course are also going to explore all of the psychology, the family dynamics, the early childhood experiences that have made us into the person that we are today. And navigating, I think, that identity crisis that I think we all naturally experience as we age and we mature and we realize that perhaps this version of us, this overachieving version of us, is not really who we want to be. We cannot live up to the golden child expectation. I think growing up, many of us who are labeled as quote unquote,|||伴随这一切而来的种种情绪。我们希望借此摆脱内化了的期望，这些期望一直在阻碍我们真正获得快乐，阻碍我们以平衡健康的方式追求想要的生活。当然，我们还将探讨塑造了我们如今性格的所有心理学因素、家庭动力学以及早期童年经历。我认为，我们还将探讨那种身份认同危机——随着年龄的增长和成熟，当我们意识到也许现在的这个自我、这个过度追求卓越的自我并不是我们真正想成为的人时，我们都会自然而然地经历这种危机。我们无法达到“金色之子”的期望。我想在成长过程中，我们当中许多被贴上所谓标签的人，
gifted or smart or mature for our age, we're very much encouraged, if not pressured, to excel. Not just by our parents or close family, although they are a huge contributor, but also by a society in general and our broader schooling and education system that placed so much value on success and tangible accomplishment. This value, this norm,
gifted or smart or mature for our age, we're very much encouraged, if not pressured, to excel. Not just by our parents or close family, although they are a huge contributor, but also by a society in general and our broader schooling and education system that placed so much value on success and tangible accomplishment. This value, this norm,|||比如天赋异禀、聪明或是少年老成，都被强烈鼓励（甚至是被迫）去追求卓越。不仅是来自父母或亲近的家庭成员（尽管他们是很大的影响因素），而且还来自整个社会以及更广泛的学校和教育体制，这些体制将极大的价值赋予了成功和看得见的成就。这种价值观，这种规范，
is so profound and impactful that I think it actually becomes part of who we are. We were the ones who had to get an A on every test, who won every school award. We volunteered whilst playing three sports, working a part-time job, doing extra credit, constantly, you know, seeking the validation and the praise from our teachers and our peers and our families. I think from the outside, that gives off the image that we have it all together. And maybe we even enjoy the sense of accomplishment and pride that comes with it, even if we know what it's costing us. But a very common experience is reaching your 20s and kind of hitting a point of burnout where you just simply cannot be that person anymore. If you grew up always being
is so profound and impactful that I think it actually becomes part of who we were. We were the ones who had to get an A on every test, who won every school award. We volunteered whilst playing three sports, working a part-time job, doing extra credit, constantly, you know, seeking the validation and the praise from our teachers and our peers and our families. I think from the outside, that gives off the image that we have it all together. And maybe we even enjoy the sense of accomplishment and pride that comes with it, even if we know what it's costing us. But a very common experience is reaching your 20s and kind of hitting a point of burnout where you just simply cannot be that person anymore. If you grew up always being|||是如此深远且具有影响力，以至于我认为它实际上成了我们性格的一部分。我们就是那种每次考试必须拿A、赢得每一个学校奖项的人。我们做志愿者，同时参加三项体育运动，打兼职，做额外加分作业，你知道的，不断寻求老师、同龄人和家人的认可与表扬。我认为从外表上看，这给人一种我们把一切都掌控得很好的形象。也许我们甚至很享受随之而来的成就感和自豪感，尽管我们知道这付出了代价。但一种非常普遍的经历是，当你步入二十多岁时，会迎来一个职业倦怠点，那时你简直无法再做那样的人了。如果你在成长过程中一直是
an overachiever, it's a pretty rude awakening to reach adulthood or university or post-grad life and come across challenges that you cannot overcome by simply working harder. You no longer have the mental energy to be this version of yourself. Or a big one, a huge one, is encountering people who are naturally just smarter than you or more creative or more talented. And you experience somewhat of an identity crisis. You know, we are no longer this exceptional gifted child. And if you are not the gifted child, the golden child, who are we? Who are we really? So we're going to explore this transition today and all that comes with it. I think being an overachiever basically means you are someone who continually performs beyond what is expected or to a really high level. That is often applied to
an overachiever, it's a pretty rude awakening to reach adulthood or university or post-grad life and come across challenges that you cannot overcome by simply working harder. You no longer have the mental energy to be this version of yourself. Or a big one, a huge one, is encountering people who are naturally just smarter than you or more creative or more talented. And you experience somewhat of an identity crisis. You know, we are no longer this exceptional gifted child. And if you are not the gifted child, the golden child, who are we? Who are we really? So we're going to explore this transition today and all that comes with it. I think being an overachiever basically means you are someone who continually performs beyond what is expected or to a really high level. That is often applied to|||一个追求卓越的人，那么当你步入成年、大学或研究生生活，遇到那些仅仅靠加倍努力也无法克服的挑战时，那将是一次相当残酷的惊醒。你再也没有精神去维持这个版本的自己了。或者还有一个巨大的打击，那就是遇到了天生就比你聪明、更有创造力或更有才华的人。于是你经历了一定程度的身份认同危机。你知道的，我们不再是那个出类拔萃的天才儿童了。如果你不再是天才儿童、金童，那我们是谁？我们到底是谁？所以我们今天要探讨这种转变以及随之而来的一切。我认为，所谓的过度追求卓越，基本上意味着你是一个不断超越预期或达到极高水平的人。这通常适用于
academic success, but it relates to things like athletic or sporting ability, our creativity, our entrepreneurship, how many things we can seemingly manage to juggle at the same time. There are some pretty clear indicators of what an overachiever looks like. And although there is not one definition, I think, psychologists often identify these types of people as individuals who focus on success, have an addiction or an obsession with success, but regardless of how much they achieve, they are never satisfied. They never feel like they deserve what they have, or they fail to see their own accomplishments and achievements from an objective perspective. When we think about it that way, overachievers are also typically perfectionists.
academic success, but it relates to things like athletic or sporting ability, our creativity, our entrepreneurship, how many things we can seemingly manage to juggle at the same time. There are some pretty clear indicators of what an overachiever looks like. And although there is not one definition, I think, psychologists often identify these types of people as individuals who focus on success, have an addiction or an obsession with success, but regardless of how much they achieve, they are never satisfied. They never feel like they deserve what they have, or they fail to see their own accomplishments and achievements from an objective perspective. When we think about it that way, overachievers are also typically perfectionists.|||学术上的成功，但它也与运动或体育能力、我们的创造力、创业精神以及我们似乎能同时应付多少事情有关。对于一个追求卓越的人是什么样的，有一些相当清晰的指标。尽管没有单一的定义，但我认为，心理学家通常将这类人定义为专注于成功、对成功有着成瘾或执念的人，但无论他们取得多少成就，他们永远不会满足。他们从不觉得自己配得上所拥有的东西，或者他们无法从客观的角度看待自己的成就。当我们这样想时，追求卓越者通常也是完美主义者。
These two personality traits come hand in hand, and they do a lot of impressive things at a high level. They are constantly challenging themselves with new projects, but they simultaneously engage in a lot of excessive self-criticism. They have a tendency to berate themselves for failing to live up to their own high expectations. They have poor work or study life balance. They are only ever focused on the future. That is a critical component of being an overachiever. And more importantly, they are motivated by fear. Fear. Fear. of failure, fear of regret, fear of embarrassment, fear of disappointing others, or maybe not living up to your potential. Maybe the person I'm describing is you. You recognize yourself in that description.
These two personality traits come hand in hand, and they do a lot of impressive things at a high level. They are constantly challenging themselves with new projects, but they simultaneously engage in a lot of excessive self-criticism. They have a tendency to berate themselves for failing to live up to their own high expectations. They have poor work or study life balance. They are only ever focused on the future. That is a critical component of being an overachiever. And more importantly, they are motivated by fear. Fear. Fear. of failure, fear of regret, fear of embarrassment, fear of disappointing others, or maybe not living up to your potential. Maybe the person I'm describing is you. You recognize yourself in that description.|||这两种人格特质相辅相成，他们在高水平上做出了许多令人印象深刻的事情。他们不断用新的项目挑战自己，但同时也进行了大量的过度自我批判。他们倾向于因为未能达到自己过高的期望而严厉斥责自己。他们的工作或学习生活平衡很糟糕。他们永远只关注未来。这是追求卓越者的一个关键组成部分。更重要的是，他们是由恐惧驱动的。恐惧。恐惧。害怕失败，害怕遗憾，害怕尴尬，害怕让别人失望，或者害怕没有发挥出自己的潜力。也许我正在描述的人就是你。你在这种描述中看到了自己。
It's probably something that you have slowly come to realize. But I think the curse or the paradox of being an overachiever is that because society typically rewards and praises people, who work hard, who stretch themselves too thin, we think that our behavior, our overachieving tendencies, they can't possibly be bad, right? You know, this can't be harmful if we are excelling, and we're also getting praised for it. But this compulsion to push ourselves to our limits is really dangerous, and I don't think that it's part of a longer-term equation for happiness. There was such a fascinating article published on this a few years back, so in the study conducted in 2019, these researchers surveyed over a thousand people who were earning over
It's probably something that you have slowly come to realize. But I think the curse or the paradox of being an overachiever is that because society typically rewards and praises people, who work hard, who stretch themselves too thin, we think that our behavior, our overachieving tendencies, they can't possibly be bad, right? You know, this can't be harmful if we are excelling, and we're also getting praised for it. But this compulsion to push ourselves to our limits is really dangerous, and I don't think that it's part of a longer-term equation for happiness. There was such a fascinating article published on this a few years back, so in the study conducted in 2019, these researchers surveyed over a thousand people who were earning over|||这可能是你慢慢意识到的事情。但我认为，作为一个追求卓越的人，其诅咒或悖论在于，因为社会通常会奖励和表扬那些努力工作、把自己逼得太紧的人，所以我们认为我们的行为、我们过度追求卓越的倾向不可能是不好的，对吧？你知道的，如果我们表现优异并且因此受到表扬，这就不可能是有害的。但这种迫使自己达到极限的强迫症真的很危险，我不认为这是长期幸福方程式的一部分。几年前曾发表过一篇关于这方面的精彩文章，在2019年进行的一项研究中，这些研究人员调查了1000多名收入超过
$200,000 who had obtained some form of post-graduation education, a master's, a diploma, a PhD, and they also self-identified as overachievers. They then asked these people three questions. Are you unhappy? Do you believe that achieving more will make you happy? Does the success of other people make you jealous or increase your level of unhappiness? Over half of these people answered yes to all of those questions. We think that tangible success and working really hard is going to make us happy, is going to create a fulfilling life. But actually what we're seeing is what these researchers call the superstar paradox, whereby the people who seemingly have it all are objectively really unhappy at times.
$200,000 who had obtained some form of post-graduation education, a masters, a diploma, a PhD, and they also self-identified as overachievers. They then asked these people three questions. Are you unhappy? Do you believe that achieving more will make you happy? Does the success of other people make you jealous or increase your level of unhappiness? Over half of these people answered yes to all of those questions. We think that tangible success and working really hard is going to make us happy, is going to create a fulfilling life. But actually what we're seeing is what these researchers call the superstar paradox, whereby the people who seemingly have it all are objectively really unhappy at times.|||20万美元、拥有某种研究生学历（如硕士、文凭或博士学位）并且自认为属于追求卓越者的人。然后他们问了这些人三个问题。你开心吗？你相信取得更多成就会让你快乐吗？别人的成功会让你嫉妒或增加你的不快乐程度吗？其中一半以上的人对所有这些问题都回答了“是”。我们认为切实的成功和非常努力的工作会让我们快乐，会创造充实的生活。但实际上我们看到的是研究人员所说的“超级巨星悖论”，即那些表面上拥有一切的人在客观上有时真的非常不快乐。
I also see this a lot with people who work really high-paying jobs straight out of university, like investment banking and such, and they always say, I'm just going to work really hard until I'm 35, and then I'll have enough money to retire. Or I'm just going to work three jobs, all of these hours, all of this year, for as long as I can, so that then next year, I can rest. And rarely does that actually happen? Normally, when we get stuck in this cycle of overachieving, we're working towards creating our dream life, but we're never actually giving ourselves time to enjoy the life that we have now or enjoy that dream. So what makes us overachievers? How do we become these people? Oftentimes, I think with most
I also see this a lot with people who work really high-paying jobs straight out of university, like investment banking and such, and they always say, I'm just going to work really hard until I'm 35, and then I'll have enough money to retire. Or I'm just going to work three jobs, all of these hours, all of this year, for as long as I can, so that then next year, I can rest. And rarely does that actually happen? Normally, when we get stuck in this cycle of overachieving, we're working towards creating our dream life, but we're never actually giving ourselves time to enjoy the life that we have now or enjoy that dream. So what makes us overachievers? How do we become these people? Oftentimes, I think with most|||我也经常在那些大学毕业后直接从事高薪工作（比如投资银行等）的人身上看到这一点，他们总是说：“我要拼命工作到35岁，然后我就有足够的钱退休了。”或者说：“今年我只要尽我所能兼三份职、加满工时，这样明年我就可以休息了。”但这种情况实际发生的概率微乎其微。通常，当我们陷入这种过度追求卓越的循环时，我们是在为了创造梦想中的生活而努力，但我们从未真正给自己时间去享受现在的生活或享受那个梦想。那么，是什么让我们成了追求卓越的人？我们是如何变成这样的人的？通常，我认为对于大多数
things that cause stress or disorder or discomfort in adulthood, the original roots are in childhood. More times than not, this is the case. And I think that is the case here. It's likely that being able to work really hard to push yourself has helped you get to where you are today. Maybe you have developed it as a defensive or protective mechanism and you have derived a lot of these expectations from your parents, from your family, from your culture, from your environment. I see this a lot with people who are labeled as gifted children when they were younger. At some stage, someone has noticed or decided that you were above average intelligence or you had more natural abilities than the average person and that they decided you are going to do
things that cause stress or disorder or discomfort in adulthood, the original roots are in childhood. More times than not, this is the case. And I that is the case here. It's likely that being able to work really hard to push yourself has helped you get to where you are today. Maybe you have developed it as a defensive or protective mechanism and you have derived a lot of these expectations from your parents, from your family, from your culture, from your environment. I see this a lot with people who are labeled as gifted children when they were younger. At some stage, someone has noticed or decided that you were above average intelligence or you had more natural abilities than the average person and that they decided you are going to do|||成年后引起压力、紊乱或不适的事情来说，最初的根源都在童年。大多数情况下都是如此。我认为这里也是这种情况。能够非常努力地逼迫自己，可能帮助你走到了今天的地位。也许你已经把它发展成了一种防御或保护机制，并且你从父母、家庭、文化和环境中汲取了许多这样的期望。我在那些年轻时被贴上“天才儿童”标签的人身上经常看到这一点。在某个阶段，有人注意到或认定你的智商高于平均水平，或者你比普通人拥有更多的天赋，他们便认定你将来会有一番
amazing things, that you are going to be exceptional. And they begin to treat you differently. They expect more from you. You get put in accelerated classes. You get harder assignments. You skip a few years at school. Everything has to be better. You always have to give more. When that occurs, you are not actually getting the chance to be a kid, to just be a kid, because you've been deemed mature for your age. So you're required to grow up faster than those around you, and take on additional expectations, responsibilities, burdens. I absolutely despise the term gifted child when it's used out of context because, A, I think, I know it sounds cheesy, but every child, every person is gifted,
amazing things, that you are going to be exceptional. And they begin to treat you differently. They expect more from you. You get put in accelerated classes. You get harder assignments. You skip a few years at school. Everything has to be better. You always have to give more. When that occurs, you are not actually getting the chance to be a kid, to just be a kid, because you've been deemed mature for your age. So you're required to grow up faster than those around you, and take on additional expectations, responsibilities, burdens. I absolutely despise the term gifted child when it's used out of context because, A, I think, I know it sounds cheesy, but every child, every person is gifted,|||作为，你会与众不同。于是他们开始对你刮目相看。他们对你抱有更高的期望。你被分到快班。你拿到更难的作业。你跳过几级。一切都必须更好。你必须付出更多。当这种情况发生时，你实际上并没有机会做一个孩子，仅仅做一个孩子，因为你被视为少年老成。因此，你被要求比周围的人更快地长大，承担额外的期望、责任和负担。当“天才儿童”这个词脱离语境被使用时，我简直痛恨这个词，因为第一，我觉得，我知道这听起来很老土，但每个孩子、每个人都是有天赋的，
they might not just show it in an academic context or a school environment. And B, it's quite exclusive. It may prevent some kids from actually getting the support they need because they termed as gifted, and see when you label a child this, you don't let them figure out their own identity. You don't allow them to be anything but what you have expected them to be. And part of that is an expectation of accomplishment and success and accolades. Not everyone wants that the older they get. Kids as they become adolescents and then adults should be able to independently determine what they want from their life. And a label that comes with that expectation might not give them that
they might not just show it in an academic context or a school environment. And B, it's quite exclusive. It may prevent some kids from actually getting the support they need because they termed as gifted, and see when you label a child this, you don't let them figure out their own identity. You don't allow them to be anything but what you have expected them to be. And part of that is an expectation of accomplishment and success and accolades. Not everyone wants that the older they get. Kids as they become adolescents and then adults should be able to independently determine what they want from their life. And a label that comes with that expectation might not give them that|||他们可能只是没有在学术环境或学校环境中表现出来。第二，它相当排他。它可能会阻止一些孩子真正获得他们需要的支持，因为他们被贴上了“天才”的标签，你看，当你给一个孩子贴上这样的标签时，你就不让他们去摸索自己的身份认同。你不允许他们成为你期望之外的任何人。而其中的一部分就是对成就、成功和荣誉的期望。随着年龄的增长，并不是每个人都想要这些。孩子们在成为青少年然后步入成年后，应该能够独立决定他们想要从生活中得到什么。而带有这种期望的标签可能不会给他们提供这样的
opportunity. And there's been research on this. One of the most exciting pieces of like research around this was a eight decade long study, 80 years conducted at Stanford University starting back before World War I. And what they did was they followed children who were very bright as kids for their entire lives observing them every three years and they identified this phenomenon known as early ripe, early rot. The researchers expected these formerly gifted kids to be happier, to be making more money, to be successful, to be fulfilled. And that was the case sometimes. But beyond the tangible success, many of the individuals that they watched actually faced significantly more emotional problems as they grew up. They reported that their self-concept was really excessively based on being intelligent.
opportunity. And there's been research on this. One of the most exciting pieces of like research around this was a eight decade long study, 80 years conducted at Stanford University starting back before World War I. And what they did was they followed children who were very bright as kids for their entire lives observing them every three years and they identified this phenomenon known as early ripe, early rot. The researchers expected these formerly gifted kids to be happier, to be making more money, to be successful, to be fulfilled. And that was the case sometimes. But beyond the tangible success, many of the individuals that they watched actually faced significantly more emotional problems as they grew up. They reported that their self-concept was really excessively based on being intelligent.|||机会。这方面也有过相关研究。其中最令人兴奋的研究之一是一项历时八个十年的研究，即在第一次世界大战之前开始、在斯坦福大学进行的长达80年的研究。他们的做法是，对小时候非常聪明的儿童进行了一生的跟踪调查，每三年观察他们一次，并确定了一种被称为“早熟早衰”的现象。研究人员原本预计这些曾经的天才儿童会更快乐、赚更多钱、获得成功、生活充实。有时情况确实如此。但除了切实的成功之外，他们观察到的许多人在长大后实际上面临着更多显著的情绪问题。他们报告说，他们的自我概念在很大程度上过度建立在自己很聪明这一点上。
So they were really never given a chance to see who they were beyond that. They experienced a lot of self-doubt. They felt like their life path was kind of determined for them. And I think often when we prioritize tangible success over the smaller joys in our lives, we miss out on the things that actually bring beauty. We don't see our friends. We don't travel. We don't take time to rest.
So they were really never given a chance to see who they were beyond that. They experienced a lot of self-doubt. They felt like their life path was kind of determined for them. And I think often when we prioritize tangible success over the smaller joys in our lives, we miss out on the things that actually bring beauty. We don't see our friends. We don't travel. We don't take time to rest.|||所以他们实际上从来没有机会去了解除此之外的自己是谁。他们经历了大量的自我怀疑。他们觉得自己的生活道路似乎是为他们注定的。而且我认为，通常当我们把切实的成功置于生活中的小确幸之上时，我们会错过那些真正带来美好事物。我们不见朋友。我们不旅行。我们不花时间休息。
we don't invest in our relationships. It's really similar to what psychologists call golden child syndrome. So a golden child is someone who is considered special by their family and chosen as kind of like a proxy for their parents' own achievements. Unfortunately, this child must live up to perhaps unattainable levels of perfection because they constantly need to satisfy their parents or in some case they kind of act as like a symbolic trophy for their parents to show off and so that they can kind of point to their child and say, look, we raised them.
we don't invest in our relationships. It's really similar to what psychologists call golden child syndrome. So a golden child is someone who is considered special by their family and chosen as kind of like a proxy for their parents' own achievements. Unfortunately, this child must live up to perhaps unattainable levels of perfection because they constantly need to satisfy their parents or in some case they kind of act as like a symbolic trophy for their parents to show off and so that they can kind of point to their child and say, look, we raised them.|||我们不投入精力维系人际关系。这真的非常类似于心理学家所说的“金童综合征”。所以“金童”就是被家庭视为特殊的人，并被选为父母自身成就的一种代理人。不幸的是，这个孩子必须达到也许无法企及的完美高度，因为他们不断需要满足父母，或者在某些情况下，他们有点像父母炫耀的象征性奖杯，这样父母就可以指着自己的孩子说，看，这是我们养大的。
So we must be doing something right. They wouldn't be that smart, that talented if we weren't also smart and talented. So unsurprisingly, at that level, most psychologists suggest that one or both of the parents is probably narcissistic on some level. maybe they're even experiencing parentification whereby the role of the parent and the child is reversed. You have to support your parents emotionally by validating them through your accomplishments. But after a while, those standards that your parents have kind of forced on you become self-imposed. They begin to really matter to you because you've been exposed to them enough.
So we must be doing something right. They wouldn't be that smart, that talented if we weren't also smart and talented. So unsurprisingly, at that level, most psychologists suggest that one or both of the parents is probably narcissistic on some level. maybe they're even experiencing parentification whereby the role of the parent and the child is reversed. You have to support your parents emotionally by validating them through your accomplishments. But after a while, those standards that your parents have kind of forced on you become self-imposed. They begin to really matter to you because you've been exposed to them enough.|||所以我们一定做对了什么。如果我们自己不聪明、没有天赋，他们就不会那么聪明、那么有天赋。因此毫不奇怪，在那个层面上，大多数心理学家认为其中一位或双亲可能在某种程度上具有自恋倾向。也许他们甚至正在经历“父母化”过程，即父母和孩子的角色发生了倒置。你必须通过你的成就来肯定他们，从而在情感上支持你的父母。但过了一段时间，你父母强加给你的那些标准就变成了自我强加的标准。它们开始对你真正重要，因为你接触它们够多了。
They've become repetitive. so no longer is it, I have to practice for five hours, otherwise my parents will be disappointed. Soon it becomes what we call introjected motivation. I have to work hard, otherwise I will feel guilty. Even when my parents, my family is not around, even when no one is telling me to be this version of myself, I have been indoctrinated into this ideology of success. That is how an overachiever emerges. this is super common within eldest children in particular.
They've become repetitive. so no longer is it, I have to practice for five hours, otherwise my parents will be disappointed. Soon it becomes what we call introjected motivation. I have to work hard, otherwise I will feel guilty. Even when my parents, my family is not around, even when no one is telling me to be this version of myself, I have been indoctrinated into this ideology of success. That is how an overachiever emerges. this is super common within eldest children in particular.|||它们变得重复。所以不再是“我必须练习五个小时，否则我父母会失望”。很快，这就变成了我们所说的“内射动机”。“我必须努力工作，否则我会感到内疚。”即使我的父母、我的家人不在身边，即使没有人告诉我必须成为这个版本的自己，我也已经被灌输了这种成功意识形态。这就是一个追求卓越者的诞生过程。这在老大当中尤其普遍。
I think because so much family pressure gets placed on them to set the standard for younger siblings, they feel more of a responsibility to maybe support the family, to keep the family going. We could honestly get into a whole separate episode on what it means to be the eldest daughter, specifically. But oh my God, that is a whole other psychological profile to dissect. We do not have time. but I also think that being an overachiever may have become somewhat of a survival tool for a lot of us when we were younger. There are three specific reasons for that. Firstly, your academic, sporting, musical accomplishments, whatever they were, they allowed you to please the people around you. And they were essentially a protective mechanism against anger or disappointment.
I think because so much family pressure gets placed on them to set the standard for younger siblings, they feel more of a responsibility to maybe support the family, to keep the family going. We could honestly get into a whole separate episode on what it means to be the eldest daughter, specifically. But oh my God, that is a whole other psychological profile to dissect. We do not have time. but I also think that being an overachiever may have become somewhat of a survival tool for a lot of us when we were younger. There are three specific reasons for that. Firstly, your academic, sporting, musical accomplishments, whatever they were, they allowed you to please the people around you. And they were essentially a protective mechanism against anger or disappointment.|||我想，由于太多的家庭压力压在他们肩上，要求他们为弟妹树立榜样，他们会觉得更有责任去支持家庭，维持家庭运转。老实说，我们可以单独做一期节目来讨论身为长女究竟意味着什么。但是，天哪，那是另一个需要剖析的心理画像了。我们没有时间。但我同时也认为，对于我们当中的许多人来说，在年幼时，追求卓越可能在某种程度上成了一种生存工具。这有三个具体原因。首先，你的学业、体育、音乐成就，无论是什么成就，都能让你取悦周围的人。它们本质上是一种抵御愤怒或失望的保护机制。
If you were this perfect child, no one could find fault with you. and you are safe. Secondly, being an overachieber may have enabled you to survive in a social environment where you felt left out. If you worked hard enough, you could leave your hometown. You could get as far away as possible from the people you grew up with or you went to school with. You could leave this kind of life that made you unhappy. It may also be that you used work and achievement and grades, whatever it was, as a proxy for self-worth and self-esteem. For many of us, I think our over-achievement, at the end of the day, stems from feelings of insecurity and inadequacy. Maybe you didn't feel great in your own skin. You weren't the funniest
If you were this perfect child, no one could find fault with you. and you are safe. Secondly, being an overachieber may have enabled you to survive in a social environment where you felt left out. If you worked hard enough, you could leave your hometown. You could get as far away as possible from the people you grew up with or you went to school with. You could leave this kind of life that made you unhappy. It may also be that you used work and achievement and grades, whatever it was, as a proxy for self-worth and self-esteem. For many of us, I think our over-achievement, at the end of the day, stems from feelings of insecurity and inadequacy. Maybe you didn't feel great in your own skin. You weren't the funniest|||如果你是个完美的乖孩子，没有人能挑出你的毛病，你就是安全的。其次，成为一个追求卓越者可能使你在一个让你感到被冷落的社交环境中生存下来。如果你足够努力，你就可以离开你的家乡。你可以尽可能远离和你一起长大或一起上学的人。你可以离开这种让你不愉快的生活。也可能是你把工作、成就和成绩——无论是什么——当作自我价值和自尊的替代品。对于我们许多人来说，我认为我们对卓越的过度追求，说到底源于不安全感和不胜任感。也许你对自己的外表或状态感到很不自在。你不是最有趣的
person, or the most attractive, or the most popular, or the most creative, but you could be the most hardworking. Therefore, we begin to conflate our self-worth, our self-concept, how we feel about ourselves with external validation. We need that buzz of being told that we've done well. We need to receive praise or awards. We want to be that person, that version of us who quote unquote does it all. So to give up being an overachiever, to give up working yourself to exhaustion, you would have to give up a really core element and foundation of your identity. You know, you do not know who you are without your accomplishments. I think this makes a lot of sense as well in the kind of society we're living in today where we really do expect everyone to be exceptional and accomplished
person, or the most attractive, or the most popular, or the most creative, but you could be the most hardworking. Therefore, we begin to conflate our self-worth, our self-concept, how we feel about ourselves with external validation. We need that buzz of being told that we've done well. We need to receive praise or awards. We want to be that person, that version of us who quote unquote does it all. So to give up being an overachiever, to give up working yourself to exhaustion, you would have to give up a really core element and foundation of your identity. You know, you do not know who you are without your accomplishments. I think this makes a lot of sense as well in the kind of society we're living in today where we really do expect everyone to be exceptional and accomplished|||人，不是最有吸引力的，不是最受欢迎的，也不是最有创造力的，但你可以是最勤奋的。因此，我们开始将我们的自我价值、自我概念、我们对自己的感觉与外部的认可混为一谈。我们需要那种听到自己做得很好的兴奋感。我们需要获得表扬或奖项。我们想成为那种人，那个所谓的“什么都能做到”的自己。所以，要放弃做一个追求卓越的人，要放弃让自己劳累到筋疲力尽，你就必须放弃你身份认同中一个非常核心的要素和基础。你知道的，如果没有了成就，你根本不知道自己是谁。我认为这在我们今天所处的社会中也很有道理，在当今社会，我们确实期望每个人都出类拔萃、有所成就，
and there is such a high degree of competition to get into university or to get that internship or that dream job, there's just also a general fascination with hustle culture, with success, with being a millionaire, with productivity. So in those situations, it may be why, despite feeling really exhausted, really burnt out, we continue to grind away, we continue to just keep working. One of the final reasons that is really significant is that we overwork ourselves as a distraction for the other things that we're dealing with. For example, I remember when I experienced like heartbreak for the first time. I worked so much harder in my classes. I studied more than I ever had before. I just like took on so many different responsibilities and this pattern of behavior
and there is such a high degree of competition to get into university or to get that internship or that dream job, there's just also a general fascination with hustle culture, with success, with being a millionaire, with productivity. So in those situations, it may be why, despite feeling really exhausted, really burnt out, we continue to grind away, we continue to just keep working. One of the final reasons that is really significant is that we overwork ourselves as a distraction for the other things that we're dealing with. For example, I remember when I experienced like heartbreak for the first time. I worked so much harder in my classes. I studied more than I ever had before. I just like took on so many different responsibilities and this pattern of behavior|||而且要考入大学、获得那个实习机会或理想工作竞争是如此激烈，人们对内卷文化、成功、成为百万富翁以及生产力也有一种普遍的迷恋。所以在那种情况下，这可能就是为什么尽管感到非常疲惫、严重倦怠，我们依然继续苦苦煎熬，继续不停地工作。另一个非常重要的最终原因是，我们过度工作是为了转移注意力，以应对我们正在处理的其他事情。例如，我记得当我第一次经历失恋的时候。我在课堂上工作得更努力了。我比以往任何时候都更加努力地学习。我只是承担了许多不同的责任，而这种行为模式
was actually a reaction to that deeper emotional distress and discomfort where if I buried myself in work, it would mean that I never had to give myself time to really think about how. I was feeling. You know, out of sight, out of mind, right? So you exhaust yourself with a million commitments and goals and projects so that you don't have to see what you're really needing to deal with in those moments. At the end of the day, focusing on achievement, working yourself to the point of burnout again and again, for whatever reason, is a type of obsessive behavior. And obsessive behaviors are rarely what they seem at the surface level. Normally they stem from needing control, needing a sense of safety or security or to feel better about ourselves. So I think we know that,
was actually a reaction to that deeper emotional distress and discomfort where if I buried myself in work, it would mean that I never had to give myself time to really think about how. I was feeling. You know, out of sight, out of mind, right? So you exhaust yourself with a million commitments and goals and projects so that you don't have to see what you're really needing to deal with in those moments. At the end of the day, focusing on achievement, working yourself to the point of burnout again and again, for whatever reason, is a type of obsessive behavior. And obsessive behaviors are rarely what they seem at the surface level. Normally they stem from needing control, needing a sense of safety or security or to feel better about ourselves. So I think we know that,|||实际上是对那种更深层次的情感痛苦和不适的一种反应：如果我把自己埋头于工作中，那就意味着我永远不必给自己时间去真正思考我的感受。你知道的，眼不见心不烦，对吧？所以你用无数的承诺、目标和项目把自己累垮，这样你就不用去面对自己在那些时刻真正需要处理的事情。说到底，专注于成就，一次又一次地把自己累到精疲力竭，无论出于什么原因，都是一种强迫性行为。而强迫性行为很少像表面上看起来的那样。通常它们源于对控制的需求、对安全感的需求，或者是为了让我们对自己感觉更好。所以我想我们都知道这一点，
but a lot of people might make the argument that being an overachiever isn't the worst thing in the world. It probably isn't. You know, there are so many other things that do sit heavy on our mind. And I actually posted a video about this the other day and someone commented being like, you only hate on overachievers because you could never do what they do. Like, you're a failure, so you're just jealous. And I was like, you know, firstly, ouch, unnecessary. But secondly, that is not the point. You can still admire the things that you have been able to achieve whilst realizing that maybe you didn't need to push yourself to the point of needing to achieve that much. You know, the point here is these people may have everything that they have wanted,
but a lot of people might make the argument that being an overachiever isn't the worst thing in the world. It probably isn't. You know, there are so many other things that do sit heavy on our mind. And I actually posted a video about this the other day and someone commented being like, you only hate on overachievers because you could never do what they do. Like, you're a failure, so you're just jealous. And I was like, you know, firstly, ouch, unnecessary. But secondly, that is not the point. You can still admire the things that you have been able to achieve whilst realizing that maybe you didn't need to push yourself to the point of needing to achieve that much. You know, the point here is these people may have everything that they have wanted,|||但许多人可能会辩称，作为一个追求卓越的人并不是世界上最糟糕的事情。可能确实不是。你知道，还有那么多其他事情沉重地压在我们的心头。其实我前几天发了一个关于这个的视频，有人评论说：“你讨厌追求卓越的人，只是因为你永远做不到他们做的事。就像你是个失败者，所以你只是嫉妒。”然后我想：“你知道的，首先，哎哟，大可不必。但其次，重点不是这个。”你依然可以钦佩你所取得的成就，同时意识到也许你不需要把自己逼到需要取得那么多成就的地步。你知道，这里的重点是，这些人可能拥有了他们想要的一切，
everyone might think that they are super impressive and incredible, but are they really happy? What's the cost here? We are going to discuss all of that and more, also including how to heal that former gifted child version of yourself after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience
everyone might think that they are super impressive and incredible, but are they really happy? What's the cost here? We are going to discuss all of that and more, also including how to heal that former gifted child version of yourself after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience|||每个人都可能认为他们超级了不起、令人难以置信，但他们真的快乐吗？这里的代价是什么？在短暂的广告休息之后，我们将讨论所有这些以及更多内容，还将包括如何治愈那个曾经是天才儿童的自己。《2%》。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，如何培养心理韧性、保持体能以及建立抗压能力。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，透过那些不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学迷雾，
that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world, are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world, are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.|||这些伪科学充斥着整个健康产业。我们曾坚信种子油天生会引起炎症。我们搞错了。世界上让我们感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你终将蜕变成一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.|||请收听《2%》。即TWO%。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打小吉姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。
What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill. Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence.
What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill. Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence.|||乔治·布什跟小吉姆到底有什么关系。好吧，你可以在《回看过去》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当年发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。其中包括最近的一集，马克·拉蒙特·希尔滔滔不绝地谈论20世纪80年代的可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时准备聊聊可卡因，但只是让你们大家知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们第二期讨论可卡因了。所以我开始看出一条主线了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病。谢谢你把那句话说完。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a deck. of my own experience in the middle health field
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a deck. of my own experience in the middle health field|||我认为没有比这更重要的黑人年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。请在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的平台上收听《回看过去》。欢迎来到我的新播客《吃一堑长一智》，我是主持人、你最喜爱的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了一套......我在心理健康领域的亲身经历，
and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough.
and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough.|||以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐本身，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.|||因为人们盯着记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯。因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要。你成为一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两个不同的动机，兄弟。完全正确。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd|||那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正成为一个好人。加入我基尔·盖恩斯的行列，让我们在我的新播客《吃一堑长一智》中，就治愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的IHeart Radio应用。搜索《吃一堑长一智》并立即收听。2023年，《单身汉》前明星克莱顿·埃克德
found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in selling, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in selling, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.|||发现自己身处亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法院听证会暴露了她证词中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的法庭之争，以证明真相。埃伦，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。动用了一大批互联网侦探才破获此案。我希望人们能看到他们的税都被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, and Michael Marincini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, and Michael Marincini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.|||他们将揭露出一个令人不安的规律。还有两名男子经历了同样的事情。格雷格，一个女同性恋者，以及迈克尔·曼林奇尼。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《情陷囹圄》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Being an overachiever is kind of like a drug because despite how destructive it is, you will undoubtedly receive praise. You will be rewarded for doing things that others cannot do or aren't capable of doing. And that praise, that admiration is something that we can't help but live for. It feels really nice to be recognized and celebrated. So there's no question that accomplishment brings a source of energy, it brings a source of strength. It's important to feel like, yes, I can do this thing.
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Being an overachiever is kind of like a drug because despite how destructive it is, you will undoubtedly receive praise. You will be rewarded for doing things that others cannot do or aren't capable of doing. And that praise, that admiration is something that we can't help but live for. It feels really nice to be recognized and celebrated. So there's no question that accomplishment brings a source of energy, it brings a source of strength. It's important to feel like, yes, I can do this thing.|||女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。请在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的平台上收听《情陷囹圄》播客。作为一个追求卓越的人，这有点像吸毒，因为尽管它具有毁灭性，但你毫无疑问会受到赞扬。你会因为做了别人做不到或没有能力做的事而受到奖励。而这种赞扬、这种钦佩是我们情不自禁为之生活的动力。被认可和庆祝的感觉真的很好。所以毫无疑问，成就带来了能量的源泉，它带来了力量的源泉。感觉“是的，我能做到这件事”是很重要的。
Yes, I have worth. Yes, I can bring something to the table. But the thing is, as overachievers or as recovering overachievers, you're not actually gaining anything from your accomplishments other than a sense that you'll need to work harder for the next. For the average person, achieving something gives them a sense of pride, it gives them a confidence boost, might even allow them to relax for a little bit, give themselves a pat on the back for a job well done. That reaction does not exist in overachievers, whereby our successes do not serve to reinforce our sense of self-worth or feel comfort in the fact that we are doing a good job. They just create more self-doubt, whereby we constantly need to be one-upping ourselves.
Yes, I have worth. Yes, I can bring something to the table. But the thing is, as overachievers or as recovering overachievers, you're not actually gaining anything from your accomplishments other than a sense that you'll need to work harder for the next. For the average person, achieving something gives them a sense of pride, it gives them a confidence boost, might even allow them to relax for a little bit, give themselves a pat on the back for a job well done. That reaction does not exist in overachievers, whereby our successes do not serve to reinforce our sense of self-worth or feel comfort in the fact that we are doing a good job. They just create more self-doubt, whereby we constantly need to be one-upping ourselves.|||是的，我有价值。是的，我能发挥作用。但问题是，作为追求卓越者或正在恢复过程中的追求卓越者，除了觉得接下来需要更加努力之外，你实际上并没有从你的成就中获得任何东西。对于普通人来说，取得成就带有一种自豪感，能增强自信心，甚至可能允许他们放松一会儿，为自己出色完成工作而自我肯定。这种反应在追求卓越者身上是不存在的，我们的成功并不能增强我们的自尊感，也不能让我们为自己做得好而感到安慰。它们只会产生更多的自我怀疑，使我们不断地需要超越自我。
Or once we've finished, maybe a huge project or a huge goal that's taken us months, We feel guilty for giving ourselves time to rest because that feels like time wasted. This really relates a whole lot to imposter syndrome, the constant sense of doubt about your skills, about your intellect, about your accomplishments, no matter how much you achieve or how much others tell you differently. Imposter syndrome is, to be honest, something I've personally struggled with for many years. I continue to struggle with it. I don't really have the solutions for you.
Or once we've finished, maybe a huge project or a huge goal that's taken us months, We feel guilty for giving ourselves time to rest because that feels like time wasted. This really relates a whole lot to imposter syndrome, the constant sense of doubt about your skills, about your intellect, about your accomplishments, no matter how much you achieve or how much others tell you differently. Imposter syndrome is, to be honest, something I've personally struggled with for many years. I continue to struggle with it. I don't really have the solutions for you.|||或者一旦我们完成了可能耗费了我们几个月的庞大项目或巨大目标，当我们给自己休息时间时，我们会感到内疚，因为那感觉就像是浪费时间。这实际上与“冒名顶替综合征”息息相关：无论你取得了多少成就，或者别人怎么对你说，你对自己的技能、智力、成就总是有一种持续的怀疑感。老实说，冒名顶替综合征是我个人多年来一直在与之抗争的东西。我仍在与之抗争。我并没有真正为你准备好解决方案。
But when I looked into the relationship or the correlation between imposter syndrome and overachieving, they are so intimately and closely related. Imposter syndrome is rarely, if not ever, seen in people who are underachievers. It's reserved for those who put a lot of pressure on themselves. when we are in that kind of place of innate self-doubt, often we experience what this author, her name is Claire Josa, she wrote this book called Ditching Imposter Syndrome.
But when I looked into the relationship or the correlation between imposter syndrome and overachieving, they are so intimately and closely related. Imposter syndrome is rarely, if not ever, seen in people who are underachievers. It's reserved for those who put a lot of pressure on themselves. when we are in that kind of place of innate self-doubt, often we experience what this author, her name is Claire Josa, she wrote this book called Ditching Imposter Syndrome.|||但当我研究冒名顶替综合征与过度追求卓越之间的关系或相关性时，发现它们是如此亲密和紧密相连。在表现不佳的人身上，几乎从未见过冒名顶替综合征。它是留给那些给自己施加巨大压力的人的。当我们处于那种与生俱来的自我怀疑状态时，我们经常会经历这位名叫克莱尔·乔萨的作家所描述的情况，她写了一本名为《摆脱冒名顶替综合征》的书。
She has this theory known as the four peers of imposter syndrome, perfectionism, people pleasing, paralysis and procrastination. The chances are, if you're struggling with the need to overachieve or you're wrangling kind of your past life, as a gifted or golden child. You are experiencing some combination of these things, perfectionism obviously being a huge one,
She has this theory known as the four peers of imposter syndrome, perfectionism, people pleasing, paralysis and procrastination. The chances are, if you're struggling with the need to overachieve or you're wrangling kind of your past life, as a gifted or golden child. You are experiencing some combination of these things, perfectionism obviously being a huge one,|||她提出了一个被称为“冒名顶替综合征的四个同伴”的理论：完美主义、讨好他人、瘫痪和拖延。如果你正在与过度追求卓越的需求作斗争，或者你正在与你作为天才或金童的过去生活进行心理拉锯，那么你很有可能会经历这些情况的某种组合，其中完美主义显然是一个巨大的因素，
not being able to be satisfied with anything unless it's the best, unless it's perfect, including in some ways your life and always wanting or working for more. There's another consequence that we need to talk about here and it feels so obvious, maybe it's not even worth mentioning, but I do think that it's an important part of this equation
not being able to be satisfied with anything unless it's the best, unless it's perfect, including in some ways your life and always wanting or working for more. There's another consequence that we need to talk about here and it feels so obvious, maybe it's not even worth mentioning, but I do think that it's an important part of this equation|||除非它是最好的、除非它是完美的，否则对任何事情都不满意，在某些方面甚至包括你的生活，并且总是想要或为了更多而努力。这里我们需要讨论的另一个后果，它感觉如此显而易见，也许甚至不值得一提，但我确实认为它是这个方程式中重要的一部分，
and that is burnout. Burnout is a state of complete mental, emotional, physical, social exhaustion that occurs when you have been pushing yourself beyond your limits for far too long. It leaves us more susceptible to getting ill, to withdrawal and isolation, despair, and just feeling detached. And it's so common these days and obviously naturally comes about during really stressful periods. It's like if you've just done all of your exams or you're in a particular busy time at work, sometimes we do reach a point of burnout. But overachievers have been pushing themselves for years. So it becomes chronic.
and that is burnout. Burnout is a state of complete mental, emotional, physical, social exhaustion that occurs when you have been pushing yourself beyond your limits for far too long. It leaves us more susceptible to getting ill, to withdrawal and isolation, despair, and just feeling detached. And it's so common these days and obviously naturally comes about during really stressful periods. It's like if you've just done all of your exams or you're in a particular busy time at work, sometimes we do reach a point of burnout. But overachievers have been pushing themselves for years. So it becomes chronic.|||那就是职业倦怠。职业倦怠是一种精神、情感、身体和社交完全枯竭的状态，当你把自己的极限压榨得太久时，就会发生这种状态。它让我们更容易生病、退缩、孤立、绝望，并感到超脱。这在当今非常普遍，并且在压力很大的时期显然会自然而然地出现。就像如果你刚刚考完全部考试或者正处于工作的特别忙碌期，有时我们确实会达到职业倦怠的边缘。但追求卓越者多年来一直在逼迫自己。所以它变成了慢性的。
And the real challenge is that burnout creates a really dangerous cycle. Because when you can no longer perform at the level that you've expected from yourself, you push yourself harder, leading to further. exhaustion leading to further self-doubt and then further attempts to repair your self-esteem by working harder again, burnout occurs. It's this whole trap. It's a mental trap. And it's why I think a lot of overachievers leave high school or university and just feel completely lost because they are completely exhausted. I think the biggest illusion that we try and tell ourselves is that we can cure our burnout by just taking a day or a
And the real challenge is that burnout creates a really dangerous cycle. Because when you can no longer perform at the level that you've expected from yourself, you push yourself harder, leading to further. exhaustion leading to further self-doubt and then further attempts to repair your self-esteem by working harder again, burnout occurs. It's this whole trap. It's a mental trap. And it's why I think a lot of overachievers leave high school or university and just feel completely lost because they are completely exhausted. I think the biggest illusion that we try and tell ourselves is that we can cure our burnout by just taking a day or a|||真正的挑战在于，职业倦怠会产生一个非常危险的循环。因为当你无法再以你期望自己的水平表现时，你会更加拼命地逼自己，从而导致更进一步的精疲力竭，进而导致更进一步的自我怀疑，然后再次通过更努力工作来试图修复自尊，职业倦怠就这样发生了。这就是整个陷阱。这是一个心理陷阱。这也是为什么我认为许多追求卓越者离开高中或大学后会感到完全迷茫，因为他们已经彻底筋疲力尽了。我认为我们试图告诉自己的最大幻觉是，我们可以通过仅仅休息一天或
afternoon off. This study conducted a few years back. It was published in the Journal of Applied Health Psychology and Wellbeing. It found that it actually takes about three months to fully recover from burnout. Three months. Now, think how long it's going to take you if you've been in a constant cycle of burnout. I always say this, but if you don't give your body a break, your body is going to take a break for you. And it is going to be at the most inconvenient time. I'm going to out myself here and say this happened to me like a few months ago, maybe about a month back, where I was just so drained. I had the most intense brain fog. I couldn't concentrate for more than 10 minutes. And then of course, I got sick. I got sick for about two weeks. And I think every time that happens,
afternoon off. This study conducted a few years back. It was published in the Journal of Applied Health Psychology and Wellbeing. It found that it actually takes about three months to fully recover from burnout. Three months. Now, think how long it's going to take you if you've been in a constant cycle of burnout. I always say this, but if you don't give your body a break, your body is going to take a break for you. And it is going to be at the most inconvenient time. I'm going to out myself here and say this happened to me like a few months ago, maybe about a month back, where I was just so drained. I had the most intense brain fog. I couldn't concentrate for more than 10 minutes. And then of course, I got sick. I got sick for about two weeks. And I think every time that happens,|||一个下午来治愈职业倦怠。几年前进行的一项研究表明。它发表在《应用健康心理学与福祉杂志》上。研究发现，从职业倦怠中完全恢复实际上大约需要三个月的时间。三个月。现在，想象一下，如果你一直处于职业倦怠的循环中，你需要花多长时间才能恢复。我经常这样说，如果你不给身体放假，你的身体就会为你放假。而且那一定是在最不合时宜的时候。我要在这里自曝一下，这大约发生在我几个月前，大概一个月前，当时我精疲力竭。我的脑雾极其严重。我连10分钟都无法集中注意力。然后理所当然地，我病了。我病了大约两周。我想每当这种情况发生时，
in hindsight, I can see the pattern of behaviours that have led me to that point. So I think all of these examples of the consequences that we face from being overachievers are important. Because I think for everyone, there comes a day when we start to question our identity as this version of ourselves. We start to wonder, is this actually who I am? Is this actually healthy? Do I want to be this gifted child and constantly live up to people? expectations for the rest of my life. And I think there are a few common experiences that almost act as triggers for us to realize that maybe our work ethic isn't sustainable, isn't as sustainable as we had thought. Or maybe that we aren't as exceptional as we've been
事后看来，我能看出那些行为模式最终把我带到了那个地步。所以我觉得所有这些关于我们作为过度成就者所面临后果的例子都很重要。因为我认为对每个人来说，总有一天我们会开始质疑自己作为这个版本的自己的身份。我们开始怀疑，这真的是我吗？这真的健康吗？我余生都想做这个天才儿童，不断达到别人的期望吗？我想有几个共同的经历，几乎就像导火索一样，让我们意识到我们的职业道德可能并不像我们想象的那样具有可持续性。或者也许我们并没有我们被灌输的那样杰出。
made to feel. So firstly, encountering people who are better than you, who outperform you, no matter how hard you try. And beginning to question, you know, am I actually special? what has this all been for? Secondly, of course, is experiencing burnout, our injury, illness, severe mental exhaustion. Thirdly, is failing at something that you've tried really hard at. I relate to this. I remember the first time I had to sit exams at university after like coming from a public school where most people weren't too focused on academics. So it was very easy to do well in that environment. And then suddenly I was in an environment of all the kids that were the best in their schools. And I just was like absolutely floundering.
所以首先，遇到比你优秀、比你出色的人，无论你多么努力。然后开始质疑，你知道，我真的很特别吗？这一切到底是为了什么？其次，当然是经历职业倦怠、受伤、疾病、严重精神疲惫。第三，在自己付出巨大努力的事情上遭遇失败。我对此深有同感。我记得第一次在大学参加考试时，我来自一所大多数人不太关注学术的公立学校。所以在那种环境下取得好成绩很容易。然后突然间，我身处一个聚集了所有学校里最优秀孩子的环境中。我当时简直是彻底手足无措。
I had this huge sense of, oh, maybe I'm not actually smart. Maybe I shouldn't be here. And I think the final trigger is having somewhat of an existential crisis about what you want from life. And realizing that accomplishment is no longer making you happy. All of these create an identity crisis. So an identity crisis, according to Eric Erickson, he's a very famous psychologist. He pioneered a lot of the research on this. it occurs when an event, a situation, makes you re-evaluate who you are.
我有一种强烈的失落感，哦，也许我其实并不聪明。也许我不应该呆在这里。我想最后的导火索是对你从生活中想要什么产生某种存在主义危机。并意识到成就已不再带所有这一切都会引发身份危机。所以，根据非常著名的心理学家埃里克·埃里克森的说法，他开创了这方面的很多研究，身份危机发生在某个事件或某种情况让你重新评估你是谁的时候。
And part of this re-evaluation is contemplating what actually makes you happy. What is your conception of a happy and a fulfilled life? What are your sources of motivation? What are you doing all of this for? All these hours. All these sacrifices. Is it for personal satisfaction and growth? Or is it another element that wants to impress others?
而这种重新评估的一部分，就是思考到底是什么让你快乐。你对幸福和充实生活的定义是什么？你的动机来源是什么？你做这一切是为了什么？所有这些时间。所有这些牺牲。是为了个人的满足和成长？还是为了另一个想给别人留下深刻印象的因素？
or appease your family or another element of you that doesn't understand that your worth is beyond your output. I think I'm going to go back to that need to impress people because I think our need to use our busyness and our productivity as kind of like a marker of our worth is huge. I used to see this in my old workplace all the time where no one wanted to be the first person to leave. Everyone would stay back past five even if they had like a no work to do just to prove that they had a good work ethic, just to prove that they were a hard worker. Another way this shows up is like bearing yourself in projects and never-ending to-do lists. This is not sustainable.
或者是为了取悦你的家人，或者是你的另一个部分，它不明白你的价值超越了你的产出。我想我要回到那种需要给别人留下深刻印象的需求上，因为我认为我们需要把忙碌和生产力作为我们价值标志的需求是巨大的。我过去在我的老工作场所经常看到这一点，没有人想成为第一个离开的人。每个人都会呆到五点以后，即使他们没有工作可做，只是为了证明他们有良好的职业道德，只是为了证明他们是一个努力工作的人。这种现象表现出来的另一种方式是把自己埋在项目和无休止的待办事项中。这是不可持续的。
So how do we recover from being former overachievers? How do we reframe our relationship with success, with productivity, with our value? Firstly, you need to have some compassion for this past version. of yourself and acknowledge why you are this way. Sometimes I see this all the time. When we identify things we don't like about ourselves, when we identify old habits or ways of being, we try and criticize ourselves out of it. We turn to like self-hatred or shame. I don't think there's any room for that here. You've already really put yourself through enough. Take some time to think back to your childhood or teenage self and just say to them,
那么我们如何从曾经的过度成就者身份中恢复过来呢？我们如何重新构建我们与成功、生产力、价值的关系？首先，你需要对过去的这个自己抱有一些同情，并承认你为什么会变成这样。有时候我经常看到这种情况。当我们识别出我们不喜欢自己的地方，当我们识别出旧习惯或生存方式时，我们会试图通过批评自己来摆脱它。我们转向自我厌恶或羞耻。我认为这里没有这种容身之地。你已经让自己经历了足够多的折磨。花点时间回想一下你的童年或青少年时期的自己，对他们说：
you didn't have to work that hard. You never had to be the best for me to still love you. You know, I'm such a huge proponent of inner child healing. And a big part of that is realizing and appreciating the environment and the factors that have made you who you are right now. Overachievement and all. You were not in control. You did not have a say.
你其实不必那么努力工作。你从来不需要成为最好的，我依然爱你。你知道，我是内耗儿童疗愈的坚定支持者。其中很大一部分是认识并欣赏塑造了你现在的环境和因素。过度成就以及所有的一切。你并不在控制之中。你没有发言权。
not get to decide what kind of values were imposed on you. So I think part of that may be by starting to realize the relationship that your parents had with success or the position they put you in as a proxy for their accomplishment or how you have conflated your value with tangible achievement. You have an opportunity now to be in charge. You are the parent now. Even if your parents are still alive and around and well, you are now the most important adult in your life. So you get to decide how you would like your future to be. But in order to undo some of those past beliefs, you do have to be nice to yourself to begin with. Part of showing yourself that compassion is, of course, giving yourself time to rest.
你无法决定被强加给你的是什么价值观。所以我想这部分可能始于意识到你的父母与成功的关系，或者他们把你当作他们成就的代理人的立场，或者你如何将你的价值与有形的成就混为一谈。你现在有机会掌舵了。你现在是家长了。即使你的父母仍然活着、在身边而且很健康，你现在也是你生活中最重要的成年人。所以你可以决定你希望你的未来是什么样的。但为了消除其中一些过去的信念，你首先必须对自己好一点。向自己展示这种同情的一部分，当然是给自己休息的时间。
I know this sounds common sense, but I also know that it can be really difficult when you haven't done that for a long time. there is such an intense guilt that we sometimes associate with taking a break, especially if you've been on the overachieving path for a while. For you, taking a break, taking a day off, in your mind is associated with choosing to be lazy, or with the stress of deadlines that keep piling up. But if you take time to rest, you will work more efficiently. If you properly restore your cognitive functioning by letting yourself switch off, your body, in mind is better able to operate. You have to remember, like, your brain is one of your most important possessions. It is priceless. You would not walk around with, like, a smashed phone that doesn't work and not get it, you know, get it repaired. You would not keep driving a car that only had
我知道这听起来是常识，但我也知道，当你很久没有这样做时，这真的会非常困难。当我们有时把休息和强烈的负罪感联系在一起时，特别是如果你已经在过度成就的道路上走了一段时间。对你来说，休息、放假，在你的脑海中与选择懒惰或不断堆积的截止日期的压力联系在一起。但是如果你花时间休息，你就会更有效率。如果你通过让自己关机来正确恢复认知功能，你的身体和思维就能更好地运作。你必须记住，比如，你的大脑是你最重要的财产之一。它是无价的。你不会拿着一个摔碎的、不能工作的手机却不去找人修理它。你不会继续开着一辆只有
two wheels and a faulty engine. You know, that is dangerous. So you shouldn't let yourself continue to operate when you know that you need rest or repairs. Practical ways to do this involves scheduling time off once a week, twice a week, once a day. The same way that you would schedule things like an appointment or study time or class or work, make rest an immovable part of your schedule like your other obligations. Because in order to overcome your overachieving tendencies, you need to treat rest and time off like an obligation. It needs to be something that is important to you. Thirdly, I would say clear your schedule and your life of the things that don't actually make you happy.
两个轮子和故障引擎的车。你知道，那是很危险的。所以当你知道自己需要休息或修理时，你不应该让自己继续超负荷运转。实际的方法包括安排每周一次、每周两次、每天一次的休假。就像你安排预约、学习时间、课程或工作一样，把休息变成日程中不可动摇的一部分，就像你的其他义务一样。因为为了克服你的过度成就倾向，你需要把休息和放假当作一种义务。它需要成为对你来说重要的事情。第三，我要说的是，从你的日程和生活中清除那些实际上并不能让你快乐的事情。
You know, that volunteer position that you have, that extra credit or extra duty you're doing at work, that you don't have time for, extra classes, side hustles or projects that you aren't really motivated by, not everything can fit into your life at once. And it doesn't mean that you're quitting. It doesn't mean that you're giving up on yourself. It just means that you're actually helping yourself by allowing more space to be focused on what really matters to you right now, by actually giving yourself permission to be happy and to have free time, recognizing that even if that thing is important to you, there will be time for those things in the future.
你知道，你担任的那个志愿者职务，你在工作中做的那些你没有时间完成的额外加分项或额外职责，额外的课程，你并不真正有热情的副业或项目，并不是所有事情都能同时塞进你的生活。这并不意味着你在放弃。这并不意味着你在对自己放弃。这只意味着你实际上是在通过腾出更多空间来专注于对你真正重要的事情，通过真正允许自己快乐并拥有空闲时间来帮助自己，认识到即使那件事对你很重要，未来也会有时间做那些事情。
And redefine your ideas of success. I read this in the Harvard Business Review that some of the top kind of regrets of people who are dying is, living a life that wasn't truly for them, and secondly, working too hard. If you don't question your motivations and definition of success now, you might be one of those people. How much more time are you going to spend in an everlasting state of burnout and dissatisfaction and exhaustion? Some really important prompts for this are the following. And answer truthfully, whether you're driving right now or you're at work or you're doing laundry,
并重新定义你的成功理念。我在《哈佛商业评论》上读到，临终之人的最大遗憾之一就是，过着并非真正属于自己的生活，其次是工作过度。如果你现在不质疑你的动机和对成功的定义，你可能就是那些人之一。你还要在永恒的职业倦怠、不满和精疲力竭的状态中度过多少时间？对此一些非常重要的提示如下。诚实地回答，无论你现在是在开车、在工作还是在洗衣服，
pause and just answer these for yourself. What would a good life look like for you in 20 years? If you could only achieve one thing in your life, what would it be? If someone asked you for your definition of happiness, what would you tell them? And are you living this definition? Are you striving towards this definition? What would you want to do with your life if there would you would, was no one watching you. I love these questions because I think it turns the attention away from
停下来，为自己回答这些问题。20年后，美好生活对你来说是什么样的？如果你一生中只能实现一个愿望，那会是什么？如果有人问你对幸福的定义，你会怎么告诉他们？你现在正生活在这个定义中吗？你是否在朝着这个定义努力？如果没有人在看着你，你想用你的生活做什么？我喜欢这些问题，因为我认为它把注意力从
socially imposed ideas of success and accomplishment and allows us to actually reflect on what we want. It allows us to contemplate life on a more holistic, bigger scale. Like, achievement feels good, but it's not everything. Getting good grades is not everything. Life is more than busy you are. Life is more than just being the best. Life is more than being the last person to leave the office or being someone that other people think is impressive. Finally, actually make a big deal out of your accomplishments. This relates to what I mentioned before whereby overachievers often undervalue their achievements and normally they just have this tendency to move on to the next task, the next project, the next big thing. And it kind of feels like a bit of a rat race at that
社会强加的成功和成就理念中转移开，让我们能够真正反思我们想要什么。它让我们能够在更宏大、更全面的层面上思考人生。比如，取得成就感觉很好，但这并不是全部。取得好成绩并不是全部。生活不仅仅是你有多忙。生活不仅仅是成为最好的人。生活不仅仅是最后一个离开办公室的人，或者成为别人眼中令人印象深刻的人。最后，真正把你的成就当回事。这与我之前提到的有关，过度成就者经常低估他们的成就，通常他们只是有一种倾向，直接进入下一个任务、下一个项目、下一个大事件。在那个时候感觉有点像老鼠赛跑
point. It feels never ending. You never actually sit down and give yourself credit for your efforts. If you got a big promotion, tell your friends, invite them over for a drink. If you got an A on your exam, go and buy yourself like an ice cream cake. Go and get yourself a little gift. You need to make a big deal out of your successes so that you don't forget them, so that you don't feel like you need to be doing more. And then when the imposter syndrome does kind of rear its ugly head, you can knock it back and be like, hey, no, I remember this really cool thing that I did a few months ago. This voice in my head is lying to me. Also, talk about your experiences as an overachiever openly. We need to be more honest with each other about the pressures that we are
它感觉没完没了。你从来没有真正坐下来为自己的努力给予自己肯定。如果你得到了大晋升，告诉你的朋友，邀请他们过来喝一杯。如果你考试得了A，去给自己买个冰淇淋蛋糕。去给自己买个小礼物。你需要把你的成功当成一件大事，这样你才不会忘记它们，这样你才不会觉得自己需要做更多。然后当冒充综合症确实抬起它丑陋的头时，你可以把它打回去，然后说，嘿，不，我记得几个月前我做的这件真的很酷的事情。我脑子里的这个声音在对我说谎。另外，公开谈论你作为过度成就者的经历。我们需要对彼此更诚实，关于我们所面临的压力
facing in our 20s, the pressures to be exceptional and the pressures to be the best. We have something to contribute. And I was speaking about this with my friends the other day when I was researching this episode. I was like, do you think that, you know, you were a gifted kid? Do you think that you had pressure placed on you? Do you think that you were told that you were too, you know, more mature for your age or whatnot? And so many of them, almost all of them admitted that they felt that way and were able to like kind of explain how that it had had a bleed on effect in adulthood. It was such a catharsis moment to realize that you, I am not the only one that doubts our abilities, who never feels like they're doing enough, who is scared of the future, scared of wasting their potential.
在我们20多岁的时候，成为杰出人物的压力和成为最好的人的压力。我们有东西可以贡献。前几天我研究这一集时，我和朋友们聊起了这个。我说，你觉得，你知道，你是个天才儿童吗？你觉得你承受了压力吗？你觉得有人告诉你你太，你知道的，比实际年龄更成熟还是什么的吗？他们中的许多人，几乎所有人，都承认他们有这种感觉，并且能够解释这如何在成年后产生了持续的影响。意识到我不是唯一一个怀疑自己能力的人，从不觉得自己做得够好，害怕未来，害怕浪费自己潜力的人，这真是一个宣泄的时刻。
It is so much more common than we know. Really, it is so much more common. I know it's so cliche to be like, you are not alone. But I think sometimes when all we're focused on is, our worth and our value and how other people see us and living up to expectations being the best, we forget that there is a whole world out there where this doesn't matter, where we are just another person who is allowed to actually just enjoy our lives. So I really hope that you enjoyed this episode from one former golden child, healing overachiever, victim of imposter syndrome to another. this topic was such an emotional release for me.
这比我们知道的要普遍得多。真的，这太普遍了。我知道说什么“你并不孤单”很陈词滥调。但我认为有时当我们全神贯注于我们的价值、我们的身价、别人如何看我们以及达到期望成为最好的人时，我们忘记了外面还有一个广阔的世界，这一切并不重要，在那里我们只是另一个人，被允许真正享受我们的生活。所以我真的希望你喜欢这一集，来自一个曾经的金童、正在康复的过度成就者、冒充综合症受害者，致另一个你。这个对我来说是一个情感的释放。
Like I feel like I personally learnt so much about what this means and what it means to be this kind of person to have this kind of personality. So I hope that you did as well. As always, if you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. I read them all.
就像我觉得我个人学到了很多关于这意味着什么，以及成为这样一个人、拥有这种性格意味着什么。所以我也希望你有所收获。和往常一样，如果你喜欢这一集，请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你现在正在收听的任何地方留下五星好评。我都读了。
It really does well my heart. So thank you so much for all the love recently. make sure that you're following along so you're notified when new episodes come out. And if you have an episode suggestion, just some feedback. If you have an opinion on this, if you are a formally gifted kid and you have something to share, I would love to hear from you. Follow me at That Psychology Podcast. Shoot me a message.
这真的温暖了我的心。所以非常感谢最近所有的爱。确保你一直在关注，以便在新剧集推出时收到通知。如果你有剧集建议，或者只是一些反馈。如果你对此有意见，如果你是一个曾经的天才儿童，有什么想分享的，我很希望能听到你的声音。在 That Psychology Podcast 上关注我。给我发条消息。
It's so great to kind of see that community growing. So thank you so much for listening along. As always, we will be back next week with another episode. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts,
看到这个社区在成长真是太棒了。非常感谢大家的收听。像往常一样，我们下周将带着另一集回归。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我剖析了我们这个奇怪的现代世界中心理坚韧、健身和建立韧性的科学。经历一些困难，你将会破茧成蝶，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。
or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. In 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
或者你在哪里获取播客。在《Look Back at it》播客中。1979年，对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何度过难关的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是一个疯狂的年份。那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with.
你正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·加姆斯主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着铠甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不容小觑的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones.
仅仅因为你有这个能力并不意味着你需要这样做。在AHA广播应用程序、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听《learn the hard way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，欧文斯女士，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Scottsdale Police.
这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安。迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。保证是人类制作的。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。